I know we've done this next story like
10 times but I have the same thing to
report to you yet again this time about
the last month July of 2016 which was
once again the hottest month in recorded
history NASA calculated that July of
2016 was about one and a half degrees
Fahrenheit warmer than the global
average over the last hundred years
scientists are blaming mostly human
caused climate change from the burning
of fossil fuels with an extra jump from
the now gone El Nino which has a pattern
of a few years of naturally warming
parts of the Pacific Ocean which can
change whether worldwide the records go
back to 1880 ok so let's go through some
of the common talking points from those
who don't believe climate change is
taking place talking point number one is
David you just said the records only go
back to 1880 that's like a hundred and
twenty years a hundred and thirty-five
years a hundred thirty six years to be
exact the earth is depending on who you
ask anywhere from six thousand to 4.5
billion years old what is a hundred and
twenty year trend tell us well the
answer is we have lots of other data
that we can look at much longer back
into history than just surface
temperatures which is only one part of
the fit the picture this includes carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and other
markers and it's it's sad when we hear
people just say that without any real
knowledge of what we can know yeah I'm
one of the big ones is how can we figure
out what was in the air thousands of
years ago tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years ago yeah called
science look up ice cores mmm ice cores
look into that and that's only one
element of course now number two we
always hear from some of these people
including on Fox News David were
regularly setting record cold
temperatures so there's no global
warming well we're talking about climate
change it's not just warming that is an
observable issue it's erratic
temperature and most scientific
consensus climate change models predict
that we would see both record highs and
let record low temperatures longer
summers in some areas longer winters in
other areas we would see changes to the
ice caps we would see increased
frequency
see of certain types of weather events
we would see drought in other areas
which we have been seeing in parts of
the United States and after a hearing
all of these talking points from the
deniers I'm always left with the same
question which is you really want to
take a chance right now this is the only
planet we have yes there are plans for
the next two four six eight years to
make a first foray into Mars but do we
really want to take a chance of waiting
until it goes completely bad before we
take it seriously and of course many
climate scientists already saying oh no
it's already going that I mean people
are already being displaced by what
we're seeing I guess it that then the
question is do you want to wait until
you are personally affected beyond any
doubt before we take action I don't
that's not the choice I would make I
don't either and yes many scientists
will say it's too late already uh but
until it starts affecting you many
people are just very selfish and and
many businesses and corporations and
polluters in general are more concerned
with their personal wealth then what
will be happening to their grandchildren
and others say this is just cyclical in
500 years it'll all be fine again well
then I guess that's only something for
you and your kids and their kids and
their kids and their kids and their kids
and their kids and their kids etcetera
etcetera to worry about but then in 500
years if they live long enough to birth
children to have children that
generation will be fine and I guess for
some people that makes them feel good I
don't know it doesn't do much for me i
have to tell you make you feel all warm
and fuzzy inside yeah we're gonna be
feeling really warm uh or maybe very
cold on the outside depends where you
are you could be cold or hot join us on
facebook we have surpassed the 50,000
facebook like mark make it one more by
liking our facebook page at facebook.com
slash david pakman show